welcome to this video playing Yevgenia
which from the US no title but very high
rating 25 something let's see i have
really bad run the last couple of games
losing i don't know how many in a row so
check this quickly it's four losses in a
row great ok ok i need to to break this
this series of bad results ok i can take
our Bishop d3 yeah I don't don't want
them to play beehive sits you betta Bowl
this is really a threat
okay let's just take and try to to play
on the slightly better better pieces at
least I hope they are slightly better
okay he's maybe playing e5 should I play
95 I could also play 94
tending night b3 feels a 5 has an ID f5
okay let's let's try that night b3 is
trying to play on the week d 6 square
with them it's not really weak but it
could be a week square with bishop g6 I
thought night a 2 here then maybe is
going to play a five
yeah still let's let's get the bishop
but it's a quite a quite on a moon yes
if I how am I ever going to take Adam
Queen takes then the Bishop c4 wine that
night on b3 are really not well placed
yeah this whole plan probably wasn't too
great looking at it a little bit deeper
the I can even retreat to the six VV
desires not sure that it is great but he
could do it yeah so this wasn't a great
idea at least night a two or so I'm
probably bad the only good thing is that
are not too far behind on the clock okay
he's his in fact retreating so yeah
let's let's get this back into the game
yeah yeah this is a very ambitious way
to play okay
yeah the night is not great on p3 i'm
not quite sure why he wants to exchange
it yeah they have this Queen d3 idea
attacking the bishop and threatening
Queen 236 not sure maybe I should have
played the appetizers go down should be
three and then threatening this but just
executing the idea is probably probably
better check it maybe didn't see it at
all or didn't see an alternative so now
i can i can also just just take h7 I
have sapna mean yeah why not actually
just take it h6 is still hanging and
what's now Bishop t5 or 95 95 maybe
Bishop takes and Bishop to e4 others
this looks looks nice just a great piece
on your form there's something better
than taking on h7 check probably not
check I take should be five I could now
can I can also improve the position
further
don't really see what you can do against
it each for I'm checking on c7 I've
prepared this the whole time to execute
it under more favorable circumstances
now look d 4 or rock d6d voice easier I
think okay still threatening rook d6
okay so should I just do that yeah come
check it slowly easier
check black resigns yeah they just
overlooked Queen g6 check I guess and
after that it was beyond repair not
quite sure I didn't really like my
maneuvers before like was certainly ok I
mean this this idea with the the whole
idea with 94 I'm not sure if this is
great it's just miss places my own
pieces I probably shouldn't be worse but
it's not really doing me much good night
he needs to take with the bishop and I
don't think there's much going on I'm
not so sure about this it is weakening
and this is a good diagonal so maybe
something like that this is just not on
Queen d3 he needs two sec the exchange
now it's probably tougher check and here
I maybe even had something better Bishop
t 54 55 is even stronger okay but this
is very good I could take h6 now okay
okay yeah I went the rack technical
route it's also should be you should be
very good yeah and this is a winning
endgame rock t6 immediately was may be
easier but it's it's a win no no matter
what yeah he should you should simply
overlooked Queen g6 check I guess okay
thanks for watching